bien mesdames et messieurs il me revient
maintenant la tâche de d'introduire et
d'animer une partie de la matinée
puisque ensuite c'est mon ami Alain
Jeandet qui va faire la dernière table
ronde d'abord je voudrais remercier
c'est pas de la flagornerie mes deux
amis qui ont exprimé avant moi Eric vert
et Luc Chatel éic parce que il mène
depuis de nombreux mois un travail de
fond assez incroyable
qui consiste à passer en vue la totalité
des problèmes de notre pays et du monde
aujourd'hui secteur par secteur en
faisant travailler des des dizaines et
des dizaines de personnes pour aboutir à
des matinées de ce genre et surtout
toute une série de propositions dans
dans des sujets extrêmement variés donc
il il est devenu une espèce de de
dictionnaire en siteique d'à peu près
tous les sujets politiques du pays de
l'économie et la sécurité sociale en
passant par la santé la culture la
défense où nous sommes d'ailleurs un peu
frités sur le taux d'augmentation
nécessaire de notre défense grand
argentier aussi donc le budget c'est
impressionnant et je vais lui dire
fraternellement mon hommage sur le plan
intellectuel parce que c'est un sacré
tour de force qui d'
arriver au moment où il y a un tas de
gens qui se préparent à toutes sortes de
PES de postes importants dans le pays
moi je dis qu'
mérite de la patrie et il est très très
compétent sur beaucoup de sujets quant à
lu qui m'a bluffé là il y a un instant
avec un tour d'horizon international
extrêmement pointu il a suggéré cette
maison au moment où elle était dans la
difficulté il y a pas si longtemps il a
fallu beaucoup de finesse de doité
d'intelligence humaine pour y arriver à
maintenir le navire à flot il l'a fait
il est maintenant en charge de notre
conseil national c'est-à-dire en gros du
Parlement du parti avec une vision
globale sur la machine politique qui est
est républicain et on doit beaucoup à
son intelligence à sa sagesse donc je
remercie et ce matin il m'a impressionné
par sa vista
internationale je vais pas être long
parce que je vais inviter nos nos
orateurs de la première table ronde à
venir dès à présent
c'est-à-dire monsieur Fabrice ballange
Jean-Marc Simon Bruno Jubert et
Jean-Paul dessiumessi je vous demande de
venir vous inst aller
à sur la tribune
installez-vous TR mots de TR mots
d'introduction sur cette matinée trop
rapidement
euh avanthier non pas pas celui-là parce
que je vais m mettre Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
décalez-vous
merciou si les ambassadeurs ça soit tout
non il y a il y a un truc qui m'a frappé
il y a de jours François Hollande dans
sa tournée des popotes préélectoral est
allé à colomber les deux
églises et s'est fait photographier
devant la tombe du général de Gaulle ce
qui montre que le général est dans le
domaine public et je me suis dit sans
doute va-t-il s'inspirer du général pour
d'abord pour mettre un peu d'ordre dans
le pays et peut-être pour enfin essayer
de trouver une vision de la France dans
le monde lui qui n a pas du tout depuis
4 ans et qui s'est contenter de suivre
au fil des événements on a parlé de
diplomatie opportuniste euh
vendre des armes oui suivre les
Américains à chaque fois qu'il y a eu un
tournant de la politique américaine on
colle la façon la plus la plus fidèle
possible c'est une version de molétisme
21e siècle auquel on assiste
c'est-à-dire une une politique
molle complètement américanisée en fait
sans grande vision nationale plutôt
droitière parce qu'on multiplie
l'utilisation de la force et les
conflits sans grand objectifs d'ailleurs
et toujours dans des positions qui sont
de subalterne en tout cas au
Moyen-Orient en Afrique c'est encore
autre chose en tout cas cet
Hommel va se voir décerner en septembre
je le dis à mes petits camarades qui
sont peut-être pas au courant à New York
par une ONG
américaine un Prix Mondial de la
Paix ce qui va venir d'ailleurs un point
n pour le début de sa campagne
électorale donc il a une une séquence
comme ça prise de séquence
positionnement qui est intelligent sur
le plan tactique qui comme on va le voir
est souvent assez creux sur le plan du
fond hier à la commission des affaires
étrangères j'ai eu une audition pénible
d'un heure et dem de de Jean-Marc hraud
qui de toute évidence ne maîtrise pas du
tout le sujet la France est environnée
de crise comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
pression de P aller dans à peu près tout
je le dirai en fin de journée avant le
discours de de Nicolas tout à
l'heure donc c'est pas une bonne période
pour notre pays et ce que disait Luc sur
l'effacement est très juste c'est vrai
en Europe c'est vrai à travers le monde
et c'est quelque chose qui qui pour moi
est une sorte d'aveux d'échec parce que
j'ai consacré ma vie aux affaires
internationales toute ma vie à les
étudier essayer de les pratiquer et
jamais j'ai vu notre voix la voix de
notre pays aussi faible clairement en
Europe on a disparu de la circulation
et dans les grandes affaires du monde
beaucoup de mal beaucoup de mal à peser
il va falloir réinventer tout
ça et
pourtant la France est à la recherche de
cet objectif si je fais le tour des des
sujets sur lesquels nous sommes en ce
moment engagés on a un problème majeur
de de terrorisme et on ne sait pas trop
le gérer on en est à 9 lois et on sait
pas le gérer
on a un problème en Afrique on a
commencé par une opération malienne on
est aujourd'hui dans une opération
beaucoup plus large qui s'appelle Barc
sans point de sortie visible ce qui est
quand même
problématique au Moyen-Orient on suit
l'Amérique on assure à peu près 3 4 %
des des opérations de
bombardement mais que fait-on que
fait-on au Kurdistan que fait-on au
Liban c'est quoi la sortie
qu'est-ce qu'on a à proposer sur
l'avenir de la de l'Irak ou de la Syrie
sa pas sur l'Ukraine on a un rendez-vous
très rapide à la fin du mois sur l'alevé
des sanctions processus de Minsk est
bloqué là encore continue à à suivre
aveuglément la politique de sanction
américaine et allemande et sur l'Europe
on a eu une convention il y a une
quinzaine de jours là encore on voit
bien que on a un rendez-vous existentiel
très important dès le dès la semaine
prochaine le 23 il y a référendum
britannique qu'est-ce qu'on va dire
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire c'est pas très
clair donc à partir de là on voit bien
que nous avons un travail nous de
réflexion à faire d'où la euh la la
matinée en trois morceaux que nous vous
avons proposé c'est très difficile de
résumer les affaires du monde on a
essayé de penser cela en en trois
parties d'abord en jetant un coup d'œil
ou un coup d'éclairage sur les deux les
deux régions qui sont les plus
immédiatement relié à l'avenir et à la
sécurité des Français le Moyen-Orient
parce que le Moyen-Orient et l'Europe ne
forment plus aujourd'hui quoi qu'on dise
qu'un seul théâtre stratégique et c'est
en soit une vraie révolution
géopolitique donc on va parler du
MoyenOrient avec Monsieur Ballanche qui
est là qui est un expert de la région et
qui est en ce moment au Washington
Institute for N poli à à Washington et
avec Jean-Marc Simon qui est en
ambassadeur de France et qui est aussi
député suppléant dans notre famille
politique donc nous aurons cet éclairage
et puis nous aurons aussi un éclairage
sur
l'Afrique qui qui là aussi Luc je vais
pas répéter ce qu'a dit Luc mais enfin
nous avons un immense problème de
stabilisation et de démographie avec ce
continent et rien que le Sahel rien que
le Sahel c'estàd les 5 pays les plus
pauvres du monde vont représenter 200
millions de personnes dans les années
qui viennent donc méga problème de mise
à plat de notre politique d'aide au
développement un énorme problème de
gestion des flux migratoires et nous
aurons pour traiter de ces sujets mon
sujet Moussi et puis surtout pardon mais
l'ambassadeur jbert qui a été l'homme de
l'Afrique au cabinet de Nicolas Sarkozy
à l'Élysée qui a été ambassadeur et son
dernier poste éétait le Maroc et puis le
et puis le Saint-Siège voilà donc je
vous propose messieurs d'être la seule
règle que je et ça va être la partie
désagréable de ma matinée c'est que moi
je suis obligé de gérer le temps et si
on veut arriver à à midi pour le
discours de Nicolas à peu près en ordre
de marche il faut que chacun ne dépasse
pas entre 5 et 7 minutes donc à 7
minutes je vais faire comme à
l'Assemblée je couperai les micros mais
sinon on tiendra pas les puis je
voudrais qu'on ait un échange entre vous
à la fin aussi donc essayez de tenir vos
vos 7
minutes donc si vous voulez on va
peut-être commencer par Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur Simon voulez-vous nous
dire un petit peu hein vous voulez
commencer vous pouvez le faire de là ou
venir à la tribune mais je vous jure que
ser
d'accord
bonjouri je vais vous parler du du
terrorisme et de son
développement dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui au point qu'il est devenu
une réalité une réalité tragique des
relations internationales c'est un
phénomène qui n'a pas été inconnu dans
le passé on l'a vu euh au moment de
l'assassinat de sad Arna ou celui de de
sarevo au début du siècle dernier après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale on a vu se
développer le terrorisme palestinien qui
s'opposait à la création de l'État
d'Israël et ses conséquences la guerre
du Liban et l'apparition du Hezbollah
aujourd'hui il a pris des des formes
nouvelles qui s'appuie sur des
motivations religieuses c'est
l'islamisme radical où le djihadisme et
on le voit Séir partout en Asie au
Moyen-Orient en Afrique et s'attaquer
aussi aux puissances occidentales voyons
sur quel terro il se développe quelles
sont ses conséquences et enfin comment
l'éradiquer en dépit des apparences je
dirais que le le facteur religieux pour
important qu'il soit sert le plus
souvent d'alibi à des ambitions ou à des
revendications qui sont politiques les
organisations terroristes ont
généralement une volonté de conquête du
pouvoir c'est le cas pour l'État
islamique pour beaucoup Haram pour les
cheab de Somalie le Hezbollah et le
hzbollah ont aussi le Hamas et le
hzbollah ont aussi des préoccupations
politiques il n'admettent pas
l'existence de l'État d'Israël mais
c'est aussi parfois le la réponse à des
frustrations politiques ou économiques
je prends par exemple le cas du Nigéria
où j'ai été ambassadeur dans le passé et
à l'époque où je venais d'arriver 12
gouverneurs sur 36 avaient proclamé la
charia dans leur dans leurs états et je
m'en entretenais avec l'émire de canot
grande
personnalité traditionnelle et
religieuse qui me disait ne vous
inquiétez pas tout ceci est purement
politique ça n'a rien de religieux et
purement
économique le nord du Nigéria a étéit
gouverné par des milit pendant des
années par des dictateurs
militaires qui parvenaient à lui donner
les retombées du pétrole notamment et de
l'activité économique du pays avec
l'avènement de la démocratie le pouvoir
est revenu au sud et le Nord est tombé
en désérrance le problème de la charia
c'est un problème
économique c'est aussi sur ce fondlà
parfois la nostalgie d'un ordre ancien
par exemple au Nigéria toujours on voit
ce peuple
canouri qui vient du l'ancien sultanat
de Bornou du 19e siècle qui regroupe une
ethnie présente à la fois au Tchad au
nord- Cameroun et euh et au sud et au
nord-est du Nigéria
c'est exactement le territoire d'action
de Boko Haram pour daesh c'est aussi un
peu la même chose avec ce rêve euh de
l'ancien califat supposé de de l'Empire
ottoman puis rêver après la chute de
celui-ci au Mali au Niger les différents
groupes terroristes organisés armé à
partir d'Algérie ou de la Libye sur fond
de de trafic de toutes sortes et
notamment de stupéfiants on
prospéré sur des revendications
ethniques euh notamment des toireges et
d'autres minorités qui sontign é depuis
trop longtemps par les autorités
rappelons aussi que dans toute l'Afrique
subsaharienne l'Islam a toujours été
modéré sous l'influence notamment des
confrériies au Sénégal mais pas
seulement au Sénégal alors le résultat
en tout cas de cette prolifération sont
considérables ce sont des zones immenses
qui sont déstabilisées et dont le
développement et la stabilité sont sont
compromises on a vu avec les attentes de
Waga ce de Grand Bassam en Côte d'Ivoire
et puis également dans nos pays nous le
savons depuis le 11 septembre 2001 la
Grande-Bretagne la Belgique la France
pays qui sont accusés de faire barrage
au terrorisme le tout servi par la
présence dans nos pays de fortes
communautés musulmanes mal intégré le
mal s'étend et fait Tach d'huile la
menace est devenue permanente imprévis
on l'a vu encore il y a de jours avec
l'assassinat de ce couple de de
policiers dans les ivnines et il n'est
pas excessif de dire que nous sommes en
guerre cette guerre nous devons donc y
faire face et la gagner c'est évident la
question n'est plus de savoir qui l'a
déclaré comme on l'entend parfois et
quelle pourrait être nos
responsabilités la question est de
savoir comment s'y prend-on pour pour
éradiquer la menace et réduire
l'adversaire on ne négocie pas avec les
organisations terroristes il faut donc
les détruire et négliger pour cela aucun
moyen c'est donc une action tousasimute
qu'il faut entreprendre ces groupes
sachons-le ne représentent que quelques
milliers d'hommes quelques dizaines au
BAMO dans l'ensemble du monde disperser
ici et là et relever le défi et donc à
notre portée la force doit être employée
bien entendu et c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui se passe au moyen
comme en Afrique mais il ne suffit pas
de frapper de manière frontale il faut
s'attaquer aussi à l'environnement de
ces groupes à leur approvisionnement au
débouchés de leurs produits de trafic et
la force ne doit pas être utilisée de
manière de n'importe quelle manière de
façon désordonnée comme c'est trop
souvent le cas et elle doit
s'accompagner comme ça a été relevé il y
a un instant par des plans de règlement
et de sortie de crise aujourd'hui
dramatiquement absent l'efficacité
commande que nous concertions avec les
pays intéressés avec nos principaux
alliés bien entendu avec l'OTAN avec
l'Union européenne et avec les Russes
aussi que l'on néglige un peu trop ces
dernières années la France ne doit pas
craindre de prendre des initiatives et
d'exercer son
leadership sa diplomatie sait quand elle
en a la volonté faire preuve de
volontarisme et faire aboutir ses
projets l'échange d'information et de
renseignement est essentiel j'observe
qu'il existe en Afrique notamment une
multitude d'organismes de concertation
qui ne se parlent pas entre eux et qui
ne fonctionne bien souvent que sur le
papier la France doit dans ce domaine
faire des propositions pour une gestion
plus efficace des données dans le cadre
des coopérations policières et il ne
fait pas de doute qu'elle sera écoutée
notre notre diplomatie doit aussi
procéder à une évaluation sans
complaisance des diverses situations ne
pas fermer les yeux sur les agissements
aostensible ou dissimulé de tel ou tel
pays je pense à l'Arabie Saoudite au
Qatar à la Turquie aussi et au Sahel
elle doit s'appliquer à imaginer avec
les autorités des pays concernés des
solutions pour réintégrer les minorités
dans la vie nationale en Syrie elle doit
être en pointe dans le processus de paix
et sans à priori la lutte contre la
menace TER n'est pas perdu d'avance
pourvu que la France redevienne
elle-même qu'elle sache utiliser le
capital de connaissance et de sympathie
dont elle dispose en Afrique et au
Proche Orient le combat doit être gagné
car le terrorisme n'est pas une
fatalité
bien merci beaucoup
pour ce message
d'espoir je crains que pour ma part je
sois infiniment plus inquiet contte tenu
de ce que je sais de la situation du
proch Orient mais peut-être avant de
faire une sorte de synthèse monsieur
Balanche vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
justement ce qui s'y passe
allez-y merci si je peux voir la
première diapositive s'il vous
plaît donc le Moyen-Orient traverse une
une phase de turbulence qui risque de
durer plusieurs décennies depuis 5 ans
c'est-à-dire depuis le soulèvement dans
les pays arabes le conflit latin entre
l'Iran et l'Arabie saoudite a pris une
dimension très violente au niveau
régional le tout surfond d'une crise
économique structurelle de frustration
sociale de lutte pour le contrôle
territorial au Moyen-Orient qui s'est
engagé entre les principaux acteurs que
sont l'Arabie Saoudite la Turquie
et et l'Iran c'est-à-dire un axe
pro-iranien que certains appellent le
croissant chiite qui s'oppose évidemment
à l'alliance proaoudienne qui regroupe
les pays sunit la Russie profite depuis
quelques années du retrait des
États-Unis pour s'installer durablement
en Syrie et son installation est durable
en fait le Moyen-Orient se trouve dans
une situation comparable à la guerre de
30 ans qui a ensanglanté l'Europe au 17e
siècle un conflit communautaire rattrapé
par la géopolitique alors je préfère le
terme communautaire à celui de religieux
parce que ceux qui s'affrontent
aujourd'hui sont de naissance chiit
sunnites cela fait partie de leur
culture ce ne sont pas des convertis
comme durant les gardes de religion 16e
siècle par exemple qui se battent pour
la faire triompher à l'exception notable
évidemment de daesh l'État islamique
parce que là il exerce une attractivité
qui dépasse les frontières il suscite
des conversions et provoque la
radicalisation d'une partie des
musulmans
sunites dans ce conflit euh géopolitique
il faut bien noter que les États-Unis
sont dans une phase de retrait durable
du Moyen-Orient euh il suffit de lire le
testament géopolitique d'Obama publié
dans l'Atlantique pour montrer que il se
tourne aujourd'hui vers l'Asie orientale
et à mon avis quel que soit le nouveau
président nouvelle présidente américaine
et bien ça c'est une c'est quelque chose
de fond qu'il faut prendre en compte et
l'Europe a donc l'obligation de
s'intéresser davantage au Moyen-Orient
parce que nous sommes évidemment en
première ligne pour l'immigration et
pour le terrorisme le Moyen-Orient a
énormément de problèmes il faut parler
du contexte économique qui est une
source véritable source de
déstabilisation vous avez deux types de
de pays si je pourrais avoir les
diapositives des pays qui sont
directement dépendants de la rente
pétrolière euh qui sont attractifs pour
les investissements comme les pays
arabes du golf répulsifs pour l'instant
comme l'Iran et l'Irak mais avec la
levée de l'embargo américain sur sur
l'Iran l'Iran va devenir une nouvelle
puissance économique dans la région et
que nous devons le prendre en compre et
puis nous avons des pays périphérique
dépendant de cette rente pétrolières la
rente indirecte la Jordanie l'Égypte le
Liban par exemple le Yémen également
enfin ce qu'il en reste qui sont
complètement dépendants les uns de
l'Arabie Saoudite les autres de l'Iran
le passage
d'une économie dirigiste dans les années
80 90 à une économie libérale de
production a échoué du fait d'une
mauvaise gestion mais également du fait
de cette r pétrolières qui crée ce qu'on
appelle le phénomène en économie du
malhollandais et qui détruit les
structures de production dans notamment
dans les pays les pays de la rente de la
rente indirecte les bureaucraties d'État
les classes moyennes se sont affaiblis
au profit de de classe supérieure
mondialisé les entrepreneurs égyptiens
ou jordanien préfèrent aller travailler
dans le golf parce que le poids de la
bureaucratie et de la corruption est tel
dans leur pays qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de travailler évidemment les
forces vives s'en vont cela renforce
l'autocratie cela renforce le
clientélisme le communautarisme et on ne
peut pas dire que ces pays soient dans
un cercle vertueux ça veut pas dire pour
autant que les économies du golf
connaissent un développement durable
émancipé de la rente pétrolière quelle
est la place du Moyen-Orient dans la
division internation nationale du
travail la main d'œuvre est trop
coûteuse pour concurrencer l'Asie l'Asie
orientale nous n'avons absolument pas de
recherche développement dans dans ces
pays ils se contentent de produire des
hydrocarbures la diversification
économique des pays du Golf est
complètement artificielle subventionné
par la rente si en 2008- 200009 Abu
Dhabi n'était pas venu au secours de
Dubaï et bien Dubaï serait aujourd'hui
en complète
faillite la question majeure aujourd'hui
c'est la stabilité de l'Arabie Saoudite
on a une population croissante 20
millions saoudien exigeante peu peu
attirée par le travail et ça c'est un
euphémisme euh une rente pétrolière par
tête d'habitants qui se réduit parce que
la consommation intérieure augmente et
lorsqu'on a une chute des prix du
pétrole et bien l'Arabie se retrouve
vite en en déficit mais les premières
victimes ce sont en fait les pays
exportateurs de main-dœuvre et
récipandièr des aides du golf comme
l'Égypte qui reçoit 25 milliards de
dollars par an de l'Arabie Saoudite pour
survivre ce qui permet d'acheter des
céréales et quelques quelques mistr
euh et ce le conflit régional avec
l'Iran qui prend qui prend l'importance
lui coûte très cher la guerre au Yémen
sans Lise et est un souci majeur parce
que à côté d'un des pays les plus riches
de la planète nous avons un des pays les
plus pauvres avec une un taux de
fécondité de 6 enfants par femme au
Yémen ce qui fait que la population
yéénite dans 20 ans sera à peu près de
50 millions d'habitants c'est une bombe
à retardement qui menace directement la
stabilité des des pays du golf et je ne
pense pas que le bombardement massif du
par Mohamed Ben
Salman va résoudre les problèmes et Si
Mohammed ben Salman justement le prince
hit enfin le futur prince héritier
[Musique]
euh à une telle violence vis-à-vis du
Yémen c'est justement pour s'imposer sur
la scène sur la scène intérieure parce
que sa succession évidemment est loin
d'être acquise le le devenir de l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est une interrogation majeure
pour l'avenir de la région à l'horizon
10 ans mais essayons évidemment de faire
face au problèmes actuels qui sont à mon
sens déjà en parti liés à cette Arabie
Saoudite sponsor évidemment de l'islam
radical et si j'ai le temps je voulais
vous parler de la la Syrie donc c'est la
deuxème diapositive qui est l'épicentre
du conflit au Moyen-Orient parce que
elle génère les principales menaces qui
pèse sur l'Europe et sur la région
terrorisme migration quasiment un nouvel
Afghanistan aujourd'hui est né aux
portes de l'Europe cette crise
évidemment remet en cause nos certitudes
quant à l'évolution naturelle d'un pays
vers la démocratie le communautarisme et
le tribalisme apparaissent au grand jour
comme finalement les ressorts de la
violence en Syrie même si beaucoup
d'analystes continuent à défendre une
thèse d'une révolution un peuple
souverain contre un dictateur
sanguinaire ou classe contre classe
alors certes ce sont des paramètres qui
existent mais ce ne sont pas les raisons
principales du conflit cette crise en
Syrie elle marque aussi la fin de la
parenthèse de 20 ans de l'hégémonie
acoccidentale sur le monde après la
chute de l'Union soviétique euh la donc
la montée en puissance de de la Russie
et de la la Chine aussi qui ont mis leur
véau sur toute intervention occidentale
en Syrie et qui ne sont pas prêt qui ne
sont pas prêt de le lever un autocrate
donc qui est prêt à tout pour conserver
son pouvoir soutenu par des puissances
tout aussi autocratiques face auquel et
bien l'Occident est est désemparé mais à
l'intérieur vous avez aussi un appareil
d'État cohérent qui soutient le régime
des minorités qui sont apeuré par la
montée de l'islam radical parce que
l'opposition syrienne laïque et
démocratique n'a jamais vraiment pesé
sur sur le terrain et en l'absence d'une
intervention militaire étrangère massive
comparable à celle de l'Irak euh en en
2003 mais bon voyons bon les les
résultats que que cela donne et bien le
régime de Bachar al-Assad n'a jamais
vraiment été menacé de s'écrouler il
peut s'étioler se réduire à une partie
de de la Syrie mais il faudrait encore
plusieurs années de combat euh pour pour
y arriver il faudrait surtout que
l'Occident il mette le prix mais mais
pour arriver à quelle situation
mais dans le cadre de ce scénario cela
veut dire qu'il nous faut accepter que
la moitié de la population syrienne
arrive en Europe nous avons plus de 56
million de réfugiés dans les pays
voisins 7 millions de déplacés
intérieurs une partie de ces réfugiés
déplacés sont en voie de radicalisation
ce qui est un processus normal vu les
conditions de vie au Liban ou en
Jordanie ne sous-estimons pas la
capacité de la Jordanie sur le plan
socio-économique à tenir le cout 1200000
réfugiés syrien en Jordanie pour un pays
de 6500000
habitants une situation où la Jordanie
est un pays complètement dépendant de la
rente pétrolière enfin de la rente
indirecte et des aides des aides
occidentales donc nous avons un risque
de de je conclus nous avons un risque
donc
de spillover de de de de d'expansion du
conflit syrien évidemment au Liban et et
à la
Jordanie pas de scénario optimiste donc
il faut nous préparer au pire en
provenance de cette région il faut donc
être conscient de de cette situation
pour pouvoir y répondre
conscient que les États-Unis se
désintéressent de la région cela
implique donc pour nous d'avoir les bons
outils d'analyse les sociétés du
Moyen-Orient ne sont pas mû pour la
démocratie le poids du sectarisme du
tribalisme du clientélisme d'une manière
générale bloque toute évolution
progressiste pour plusieurs décennies il
faut être conscient de cette réalité
c'est c'est l'irréal politique parce que
ça nous conduit tout droit
malheureusement au massacre du batacl
merci beaucoup merci Monsieur Balanche
remettez la la diapo là
juste un mot de de synthèse avant que je
passe à l'Afrique parce que c'est très
important ce qui a été dit mettez la la
diapo
précédente la nouveauté fondamentale des
des des 30 ou 40 prochaines années c'est
que le système des états tel que vous le
voyez ici et qui a été construit par la
France et la Grande-Bretagne il y a
exactement 100
ans ce système est par terre et la
grande question des des décennies qui
viennent les années qui viennent c'est
comment est-ce qu'on va pouvoir recoudre
un pays comme l'Irak comment est-ce
qu'on recoue la Syrie je sais part
est-ce que la Jordanie peut résister à
ça est-ce que le Liban peut résister à
ça vous avez une réouverture complète de
la carte et cette situation est comme
vient de me le dire monsieur Ballanche
durable ça veut dire que cette région va
nous exporter pendant encore longtemps
comme dans un cratère la lave de ces
terroristes et la lave de ces réfugiés
et donc la raison pour laquelle je
voulais commencer par le Moyen-Orient
c'est qu'on est au début et c'est pour
ça que j'ai
dit l'ambassadeur Simon avec gentilless
que mon analyse de de de de la retombée
terroriste chez nous est est beaucoup
plus inquiète pas dire pessimiste bien
sûr qu'on qu'on va gagner cette guerre
mais il faut se la il faut prendre
conscience que c'est une guerre
extrêmement dure et longue et je crois
qu'il faut arrêter de se payer de mots
et de quand il se passe quelque chose de
tragique juste faire des prières se
lever faire des des des des voilà des
voilà tout le monde est très bien on
rend hommage on dit que c'est affreux et
on continue comme avant non ce qui est
devant nous c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
grave que ce que la plupart des gens
imaginent y compris dans le gouvernement
actuel il faut qu'il y a une prise de
conscience que ceci est un autre monde
et un monde dangereux s'agissant
maintenant de
l'Afrique je vais laisser monsieur
jumousi et Monsieur jber en dire un mot
mais c'est l'autre versant il aurait
fallu une autre carte je sais pas si on
l' du sud de la Méditerranée et de
l'Afrique c'est l'autre versant de notre
problème pour les années qui viennent
l'autre évolution c'est que l'a frite
est ici de plus en plus elle est par la
pression démographique elle est parce
que notre sort est désormais commun et
il va falloir changer de logiciel encore
pendant très longtemps on a présenté
l'Afrique comme juste un problème de
francophonie d'influence de la France à
l'ONU de d'aide au développement plan
plan si on regarde précisément comment
cet argent est dépensé on s'aperçoit que
il va rarement au bons endroit qui
traite rarement les bons sujets
c'est-à-dire les taux de fécondité qui
sont juste pas possibles dans les pays
les plus pauvres du monde et qu'il faut
qu'on trouve un logiciel de moi je suis
un afro optimiste je pense que l'Afrique
est un pays un continent extrêmement
riche parfaitement capable de s'en
sortir à condition de se prendre en main
et que les le mode de
gestion par l'Europe de sa politique
africaine change du tout au tout c'est
donc l'autre versant de notre problème
et pour le traiter il nous reste 14
minutes donc un peut-être monsieur jousi
vous qui êtes entrepreneur vous allez
dire un mot de votre vécu de tout ça je
crois Franco camerounais et puis ensuite
je demanderai à notre ambassadeur
Monsieur Afrique ambassadeur jbert de
venir donner son éclairage merci s'il
vous plaît monsieur faites-le plusôt de
là de la Table Ronde voilà ça ce sera un
peu plus peut-être un peu plus convivial
et et moins magistral dans les dans les
cours qui sont assonné ce
matin
allô alors Franco camour non
afroofançais
oui je fais partie de la race
d'entrepreneur africain arrivé en France
depuis plusieurs années et je
travaille en France bien évidemment
plusieurs années et j'ai réussi à
installer une famille
d'entrepreneur ça me laisse la
possibilité de travailler également en
Afrique où j'ai passe à peu près 4 à 5
mois par an
alors je suis là pour vous apporter
l'éclairage de l'Afrique qui est comme
elle est non pas comme nous souhaitons
qu'elle soit avec toutes ces difficultés
et et tous des des contraints
d'investissement qu'on peut trouver sur
place avec ce divorce croissant qu'il y
a entre les dirigeants et la jeunesse et
avec ce divorce également qui a entre la
France et les anciennes colonies
français en Afrique on le perçoit pas
assez mais cette jeunesse a besoin de de
de de de de démocratie de beaucoup
d'autres choses d'investir de travailler
sauf queur tu as beaucoup de difficultés
que je rencontre moi-même en sonant la
le continent les difficultés par exemple
sont d'ordre financière je suis obligé
d'autoinvestir de financer toutes mes
opérations d'investissement parce que
les banques qui sont toutes françaises
notamment en Afrique prêtent très peu
aux Africains pourtant son
collecteuse la Société Générale des
toutes les banques principal sont
françaises sont françaises et
malheureusement lorsque l'on vous
demande autant de de garanties qu'il
faudrait pour investir à la mite si vous
aviez ces garanties vous n'avez pas
besoin de banque pourtant je suis parti
de céveloppement donc je suis obligé de
développer mes activités en cofinançant
en travaillant avec la diaspora et
d'autres personnes qui travaillent
également en France nous avons des flux
importants d'argent qui partent de la
France France en général vers l'Afrique
et je suis certain que on peut changer
le paradigme comme on disait tout à
l'heure
en N organisons mieux ces flux d'argent
l'aide publique n'a plus la capacité de
financer beaucoup de choses mais nous
pouvons financer énormément de choses en
Afrique également et nous sommes les
vecteurs pour apporter une parole
nouvelle de la France qui est très mal
vue malheureusement dans certains pays
contenu son passé colonial et contenu
des de ce qu'on a fait croire aux
Africains en général nous sommes ces
vecteurs là et nous pvons apporter le
dans le cas du céveloppement énormément
de de choses de mobilisation de fonds
pour participer au développement de
l'Afrique mais les règles sont assez
draconienne bien évidemment et au niveau
de des États où il manque le droit tout
simplement dans les investissement dans
les affaires publiques merci beaucoup
monsieur monsieur a dit quelque chose
très
important il a dit que la France
contrairement à ce que croit beaucoup de
Français n'est pas nécessairement bien
vu en Afrique euh c'est
vrai et ben justement monsieur Joubert
va peut-être vous vous le dire mais mais
mais c'est une c'est un vrai sujet
pourquoi ben pourquoi parce que il y a
ce passé colonial parce que même si nous
y avons versé le sang de nos soldats en
ce moment même à Barkan ou ou au
mali un la présence militaire trop
longue transforme parfois notre pays en
force d'occupation faut le savoir il
faut voir aussi que les les modalités de
de coopération n'ont peut-être pas été
toujours perçu de la de la manière dont
on croit que c'est perçu ici il est
important ce que disait monsieurousi est
très juste c'est important de garder ça
en tête monsieur ambassadeur Joubert
est-ce que vous confirmez cela par votre
analyse allez-y oui je je souscris
pleinement à ce que Monsieur J a dit à
l'instant notamment sur les banques
aussi sur la jeunesse
euh vous disiez tout à l'heure que on
est en guerre ou on a une période de
guerre moi je crois qu'il faut regarder
l'Afrique en se posant deux questions où
est-t-on des alliés et o où voit-on les
dangers alors je vais peut-être d'abord
vous parler du danger euh que l'Afrique
présente à mes yeux c'est la question de
la démographie c'est le thème qu'on m'a
donné je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement conscient que le continent
africain au-delà des chiffres euh
peut-être 2 milliards d'habitants 2050
c'est la plus forte des explosions
démographiques que nous ayons de mémoire
d'homme connu quand je dis mémoire
d'homme en remontant à 12 1300 très très
ancien cette cette croissance
extraordinaire c'est un changement
d'échelle complet ça veut dire qu'à nos
portes c'est-à-dire au-delà de Gibraltar
on va avoir un continent euh avec une
masse humaine considérable c'est-à-dire
beaucoup de de de dynamique mais aussi
beaucoup de danger cette explosion
démographique C cette fulgurance en
réalité va avoir des conséquences
majeures qui sont déjà en cours et ne
croyons pas que ça va s'arrêter parce
que une fois que les processus
démographiques sont lancés on parle de
30 ans c'estàd que les enfants qui
naissent maintenant les taux de
démographie ça changera pas avant 30 ans
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a comme
conséquence aujourd'hui qu'on voit et
qui peuvent être désastreuses
urbanisation folle en en 1900 je crois
qu'il y avait pas plus de 10 millions
d'habitants en Afrique qui étaient
urbanisé aujourd'hui il y a 38 villes de
plus d'un million d'habitants ça veut
dire un développement dans ces régions
mais pas de moyen où sont les services
publics de transport où sont les
logements sociaux où sont les autoroutes
où sont même la production d'énergie
donc un gros problème on a aussi un
phénomène moins connu qui est la
densification des campagnes alors ça
c'est plutôt pas mal parce que quand on
n pas assez d'habitants on peut pas
mettre d'infrastruc structure mais là ça
veut dire aussi aujourd'hui une lutte
parfois féroce Côte d'Ivoire que
Jean-Marc a bien connu pour
l'accaparement des terres lutte entre
les sédentaires et ceux qui ne le sont
pas les les les nomades lutte pour
essayer de de survivre dans ce dans ce
domaine et puis il y a la crise sociale
quand il y a une explosion pareil
comment fait-on pour offrir des services
de base comment fait-on pour empêcher la
manipulation politique et là je pense à
des situ comme l'Égypte par exemple qui
est africaine mais c'est pas cette
Afrique là que je pense mais l'islamisme
politique a fait son pain quotidien de
la dénonciation de la critique sociale
quant à l'organisation de la société et
ça en Afrique avec l'importation
maintenant de forme d'islamisme radical
venant de l'est de l'Arabie Saoudite du
golf en général et qui sont en train de
faire muter très profondément une partie
de l'Islam traditionnel y compris ces
fameuses confréries qu'on voit infiltré
maintenant et bien on peut s'attendre à
une croissance de la critique sociale
voire à une déstabilisation et puis face
à tout ça des puissances publiques il
faut bien le reconnaître extrêmement
démunis des états faibles des états
souvent impuissants infficacité des
services pas de rentrée fiscale très peu
et puis surtout surtout un concept qui
n'est pas celui de la nation trop
souvent mais plus souvent celui du
clientélisme clientélisme à base
ethnique cantélise à base régionale mais
qui fait que il est très difficile pour
un gouvernement de favoriser le bien
commun et à ce moment-là on débouge sur
un dernier problème qui est la jeunesse
sans avenir ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur jamous tout à
l'heure facile à recruter il faut savoir
que Boko Haram aujourd'hui recrute à
coup d'argent les les milices dans le
nord du Mali sont aussi des des milices
qui recrute beaucoup sur je t'offre un
boulot je t'offre une calage je t'offre
un scooter une moto donc on a on a ici
euh autant d'éléments et je voudrais pas
insister là-dessus sur qui peuvent qui
peuvent déboucher en réalité sur une
malédiction pour nous parce qu'encore
une fois ils sont à nos portes donc le
danger il est là est-ce qu'on peut faire
de l'Afrique un allié moi je crois que
oui et et et j'espère tout à l'heure
qu'on qu'on en reparlera mais d'abord il
faudrait de la croissance qui soit aussi
du développement on a eu beaucoup de
croissance en Afrique sur les 15
dernières années depuis pratiquement les
années 2000 on a eu entre entre 5 et 6 %
selon les régions c'est beaucoup c'est
beaucoup mieux que nous mais la réalité
c'est que ça n'a pas profité à tout le
monde il y a eu ses écart de richesse il
y a eu la prédation exportation des
capitaux très peu d'investissement local
investissement productif donc une des
premières chos à faire c'est d'essayer
comme vous le faites de développer le
socle économique d'inciter il y a toutes
sortes de mécanismes qui peuvent nous
permettre d'inciter à l'investissement
dans les activités productives même
modestes et là je pense à un point très
précis c'est qu'il faut profiter de la
densité et de l'urbanisation que je
viens de citer pour justement créer cet
effet du marché il y a maintenant une
demande dans les ville on va pouvoir
faire un certain nombre choses je vais
en dire un mot sur l'agriculture et puis
l'économie informelle celle queon voit
au coin des rues c'est la vraie économie
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour rentrer
cette économie là dans le système formel
lui donner des droits lui faire payer
même très modestement quelques taxes
l'installer là on va créer à ce
moment-là les banques vont peut-être à
des niveaux très modestes s'intéresser
donc voilà un premier une première piste
deuxième piste mettre l'accent sur
l'agriculture actuellement dans certains
pays comme le Niger où l'explosion
démographique est considérable de 7 7
enfants par femme actuellement 80 7,4 80
% de population agricole 18 % de terre
arable si on ne fait pas quelque chose c
c c'est l'explosion absolue donc là il
va falloir remettre toutes les
institutions internationales sur la
question de l'agriculture il va falloir
relancer la la question justement de
l'approvisionnement des villes des
circuits de production des circuits de
distribution de la transformation toutes
sortes de choses qu'on connaît mais
qu'on a délaissé parce qu'à un moment
donné la politique de la Banque mondiale
et d'autres institutions internationales
était de négliger et de tenir
l'agriculture pour inintéressante 3oème
élément renforcer les États et là je
crois que notamment dans la question du
terrorisme c'est absolument essentiel il
faut aider d'abord les États à devenir
les garants de l'ordre collectif avoir
des structures de sécurité des armées
des polices qui soit non seulement des
instruments de maintien de l'ordre
peut-être un peu répressif mais surtout
au service des populations et là nous
nous pouvons faire beaucoup de choses
nous faisons déjà mais il faut que ça
devienne collectif la France n'est pas
la seule à devoir faire ces choses mais
elle doit peut-être lancer les idées et
appuyer les idées et je voudrais
terminer avec une dernière justement
remarque qui est
que on a peut-être d'une certaine façon
nous Français trop désinvestis sur
l'Afrique vous disiez tout à l'heure les
banques françaises mais moi je pense aux
banques marocaines qui ont racheté
beaucoup de banques françaises en
Afrique et je crois que on a trop
facilement parce que c'était les Chinois
parce que c'était eux l'avenir parce que
c'était les pays émergents parce que les
défis étaient trop grands parce qu'on
avait peut-être des complexes d'anciens
coloniaux on a laissé filer une partie
de l'Afrique je crois que maintenant il
fa à nous Français de redire un certain
nombre de nos petits camarades européens
en particulier qui nous regarde ici et
là de leur dire les copains il faut
monter à bord il y a beaucoup de choses
à faire il faut aller voir les les
institutions nationale et il faut
relancer les choses dans cette direction
merci merci beaucoup monsieur Jubert
bien vous avez vu que c'était pas simple
d'essayer de faire tenir de sujets aussi
majeurs pour notre avenir en trois qu4
d'heure je veux vraiment vous remercier
tous les quatre d'y être je crois
parvenu je pense que tous ceux qui sont
ici ont compris
que la reconfection du ProcheOrient
et une politique africaine différente
mais mais mais forte de la part des
Français et des Européens est juste
indispensable pour la sécurité de notre
de notre continent dans les décennies à
venir voilà ça c'est les deux messages
de cette matinée peut pas y avoir de
politique étrangère à l'avenir pour
notre pays qui ne soit
absolument focalisé sur ces deux régions
prioritaires pour nous encore une fois
c'est le même théâtre stratégique et en
ce sens c'est une vraie révolution dans
l'histoire de l'Europe messieurs je vous
remercie
infiniment de votre contribution et
j'appelle vous pouvez les
applaudir